so now
if you can just give us an idea about
what was the basic fundamental
foundation
of marxism or communism well marx and
ingles said
the entire communist theory or program
may be summed up in a single sentence
abolition of private property so there
you go
i mean that's so if you had marx and
ingles in the room and said hey
um in one sentence describe communism
they say well that's easy we did in the
communist manifesto
right the entire communist theory may be
summed up in the single sentence
abolition of private property
um beyond that they had other basic
little definitions mark said
communism begins where atheism begins
and here if i may read just a couple of
bullet points
this is marx and the manifesto
marx and ingalls in the manifesto
communism represents
the most radical rupture in traditional
relations
by the way which it sure does they
acknowledge that communism quote
seeks to abolish the present state of
things
right seeks to abolish the present state
of things of all things right
i mean this is key because we're going
from abolition to private property
to abolishing the present state of
things
so people who think and and young people
say this in surveys
well communism is a pretty good idea i
mean they talk about
love and sharing and sharing the wealth
no
read the book they talk about abolishing
the present state of things
these guys aren't tinkerers they're not
talking about like
increasing tax rates right they're not
talking about adding a couple programs
to the
to the welfare state abolish the present
state of things what does that mean to
you
what does that mean to you well it in in
the in the case of when you read the
totality of what they're writing
it's it is truly a totalitarian
philosophy
and totalitarian in the strictest sense
of the word
a fundamental transformation of human
nature
i mean they are really looking to to
redefine human nature
the final paragraph of the communist
manifesto everybody remembers
workers of the world unite you have
nothing to lose but your chains
they write this in the final paragraph
the communists openly declare that their
ends can be attained
only by now listen to this only by the
forcible overthrow of all existing
social conditions okay our
ends can be attained only by the
forcible
overthrow of all existing
social conditions i mean you and i right
we
we we know this as scholars and
intellectuals
you never say all about anything right
you might say
um communist call for for the forcible
overthrow
of those things in society which are
unjust right
they want the forcible overthrow of all
existing social conditions and it marks
um here's one more phrase in the
manifesto close of the manifesto
last page of the manifesto communists
everywhere
support every revolutionary movement
against the existing social and
political order of things
now you hear that and you think to
yourself this explains a lot
right you might be watching a particular
rally on tv
a riot or whatever anything why is that
guy there with a hammer and sickle
what does that have to do with communism
wait they're protesting the unjust death
of george floyd
what's the communists doing there what
does that have to do with communism
well if whatever is going on right is
some sort of movement
against the existing social and
political order of things
these guys will be there right i mean
they'll team up if if it's redefining
um marriage or gender or whatever else
something that might you might think
doesn't have anything to do with
capitalism or anything that these guys
could have thought of in the 1840s
if it's about redefining and
annihilating the existing and
social political order of things they'll
be there
uh paul do you think he wrote this book
with angles for them to
experience the power themselves or was
it
because i read somewhere where when this
book was taken by you know lennon stalin
all those guys it was
almost like they wanted to take
ownership for what this could happen but
carl couldn't fulfill his own prophecy
what was his long-term aspiration of
writing this book
so the book came out in 1848 so he had
been 30 years old
he died in 1883. ingalls died a little
bit after that
so you know he lives for 35 years
after the publication of the book and he
talks in some of his glowing moments
about
how communism will allow for him to fish
in the morning
farm in the afternoon raise cattle in
the evening
criticize after dinner right he talks
about in this very utopian language
as to whether he would have lived to see
it if he believed he lived to see it i
don't know
but but he talked about communism as
this dialectical march of history
this inevitable march this is part of
the point of communism
this is inevitable they believe this is
the inevitable logic in march of history
in fact engels called it they called it
scientific socialism
and and engels said in his eulogy for
marx at marx's funeral
he said this is the darwin of the social
sciences
he has done for the social sciences what
darwin did for evolutionary biology
this is the natural evolution of history
so history would have would evolve from
feudalism slavery from feudalism and
slavery
to capitalism to socialism to communism
right so socialism would be the final
transitionary step to communism
lenin and the bolsheviks they get into
power
lenin at one point in january 1917 was
depressed he said i don't think i'll
live to see the revolution in my
lifetime
and then america declared war world war
one woodrow wilson april 2nd
got a war declaration in congress april
6 1917.
the czar abdicated and the germans
put lenin on a boxcar and let him pass
through
dropped him in the middle of saint
peter's square and by october of 1917
the bolsheviks had their revolution
so um and marx and lenin and stalin and
these guys they believed
lenin wrote a number of important
articles and statements on this
they believe the the revolution needed a
vanguard
a regime a cadre a group of individuals
a kind of an anointed group
to raise the consciousness of the masses
and the workers right
you couldn't just wait for this to
transcend for this to evolve
no we got to abolish this now we got to
abolish that now
we got to get to work we got to take
power got it
so if you if you're looking at it right
now and you were to say the following
countries are full on communism
what would you say is full-on communism
based on their definitions
castro's cuba the the castro brothers
right raul now fidel died a couple years
ago the kim's north korea
those are really textbook cases of
totalitarian communism
and you know and you get this all the
time somebody watching this will
probably complain
a marxist out there they say this all
the time patrick oh
that's not really communism right that's
an aberration of communism
right yeah marx and ingalls would have
never supported
the gulags well you go go to marx and
engel's ten point
what they call for the forcible
overthrow of all existing conditions
forcible overthrow
go through their 10-point plan they say
right there at the 10-point plan
of course in the beginning this cannot
be affected except by means of despotic
inroads i mean they realize any any
you're a business person any um business
person non-business person
anybody should realize that if you make
a call for the abolition of private
property
you're gonna have to use guns and gulags
i mean people aren't going to roll
over for that and right then and there
you go you ought to say to yourself if
if this is an ideology that's going to
require locking people up and killing
them and putting them on trains and
hurting them off the concentration camps
maybe we shouldn't go there
maybe this is a bad idea right
but but that's uh this is an ideology
that necessitates
prison camps i think it's unavoidable so
when you hear chinese communistic party
what what's communistic about china yeah
that's a great question
and modern china is such a weird case
right so you have you have a country
that from 1949 to 76
under mao and the cultural revolution
the great leap forward
that was full-blown maoism communism
as mao saw it right the sinification of
marxism as he saw it
and then deng xiaoping came in in
1978-79
created what he called socialism with
chinese characteristics
where they reversed the collectivization
they started doing mass privatizations
they started freeing up the economy and
basically they did
what was no longer economically
communism
so you have the weird situation in china
to this day where you have a country
that's politically communist
a one-party communist state but not
economically communist
so yeah what does that mean one
political party communist government is
communism what does it mean government
is communism
well and this is where this is where the
soviet union was right
and and the big thing that mikhail
gorbachev did in 1990
they abolished article 10 or is it
article 6 of the soviet constitution
which had a communist party monopoly on
political power
and you know every every communist state
ever
you can only have one political party by
the way and you can't have free
elections
because people won't vote for communists
right
but i mentioned the the elections in
poland in june 1989 earlier
patrick they put 100 seats up for
contested elections
communists lost 100 out of 100
okay they didn't win a single seat right
that's why castro's cuba won't hold
elections
this is why they don't hold elections
because people will vote communists out
people in the western like communism is
a pretty good idea they don't live
under it right then why don't the people
ever vote for why don't the leaders
allow them people to vote for it
so in china you have a single party
communist party controlled state
that doesn't allow political parties the
leader of the party is the chairman the
president whatever becomes the leader of
the country
and they're smart enough to realize that
if they want an economy that works
you can't do true economic communism
you gotta allow enough free market
reforms that you won't go
broke and starve to death so it's weird
what they're doing with communism in
china it's a very different thing it's
and it's totally unlike north korea
or cuba so if you like this sort of
short club from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you